du gehst dahin du hast immer Angst
vorher aber du bist dann da und in dem
Moment schaltet dein Gehirn um und du
musst jetzt in diesem Modus umschalten
der selbst Erhaltung
die Trauer nach der Explosion hat sich
in Wut verwandelt
[Musik]
es ist kein Spiel es ist echt es ist
gefährlich und es kann tödlich sein wie
zu dachten
mit denen wir hier unterwegs sind sind
sehr nervös wenn ein
hochgeschwindigkeitsgeschoss über deinen
Kopf drüber fliegt dann hörst du wie das
die Schallmauer durchbricht das sind
dann so ein kleines klappen immer
aber das Gute ist immer das Knacken wird
dann weiß man dass das Geschoss überall
drüber geflogen ist eigentlich getroffen
hat
das ist wichtig dass man als
Kriegsreporter vor Ort sich ganz ganz
nahe Eindrücke verschafft
hier hinter uns eine vierköpfige Familie
die von der russischen Armee
hingerichtet wurde
hier noch die Pläne
ich würde sagen dass ich gut die Hälfte
des Jahres ungefähr unterwegs und
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr das ist
ganz unterschiedlich
es ist so viel passiert dieses Jahr ich
weiß schon gar nicht mehr wann ich in
welchem Land war es ist oft anstrengend
aber eigentlich immer ganz cool auch
mein Name ist Johannes Arno ich bin
Korrespondent des ZDF im Moment in New
York mein Name ist
Thomas
für den Spiegel Frederik Pleitgen Beruf
Reporter mein Name ist ich heiße hinter
San ich bin Korrespondentin bei weißnews
Katrin Eugendorf
bin internationaler Reporterin des ZDF
[Musik]
ein never ich hätte nie gedacht dass ich
Kriegsreporter werden will
ich wollte nie kriegsreporterin werden
das klingt doch auch merkwürdig dass
jemand nur über Krieg berichten möchte
mir geht es nicht darum irgendwie
Kriegsberichterstattung und das ganze
geschiese und das bumbum und so mich
interessiert das einfach was da los ist
aber ich würde mich niemals als
Kriegsreporter bezeichnen was ich mache
oder was wir wissen immer im Teams
unterschiedliche größer unterwegs ist ja
nicht irgendwo hinzufahren wo es Krach
und Bumm macht und zu sagen hier macht
es Bumm und Kraft sondern zu schauen
okay was können wir
beweisen was sehen wir dass es eher
forensisches Arbeiten the Russians die
Russen wollten nach Kia vorstoßen wurden
aber von ukrainischer Artillerie und
Panzerabwehrraketen gestoppt
viele Russen sollen getötet worden sein
andere liefen davon
wenn man das erste Mal in einer
Situation ist wo es richtig gefährlich
ist dann merkt man wie man selbst damit
umgeht man cool bleibt oder und und vor
allem weiter funktioniert oder ob man
dann halt
ja echt nervös wird
plötzlich flogen die Kugeln anscheinend
auch in unsere Richtung deswegen fahren
wir jetzt schnell hier weg
Nachtmodus an
wir haben jetzt ein paar Aufsager
gemacht seit wir aus dem Hafen raus sind
wir sind heilfroh dass wir unversehrt
aus den libyschen Gewässern rausgekommen
sind
wenn man in Gebieter reist wo es ein
bisschen schwieriger ist sieht man halt
einerseits ich sag immer das Beste und
das schlimmste an der Menschheit und ich
glaube das solche Erfahrungen ein als
Personen total weiterbilden
ich habe immer eine Ost als
berichtsgebiet gehabt war in den Ländern
unterwegs auch als noch komplett
friedlich waren
ich kannte Syrien sehr gut dann brach
2011 da die Revolution aus
spiegelreporter Christoph Reuter auf dem
Weg zur Front kein anderer deutscher
Journalist berichtete seit Beginn des
Krieges so häufig aus Syrien
[Applaus]
ich kannte Irak vorher dann sind da die
Amerikaner 2003 einmarschiert im Prinzip
kam nicht ich zum Krieg sondern die
Kriege kamen eher zu mir
[Musik]
ich bin im Irak geboren als ich drei war
sind meine Eltern mit mir nach England
ausgewandert damit mein Vater studieren
konnte
wir gingen in eine Stadt namens Hall in
Nordengland dort bin ich aufgewachsen
bevor ich bei weißnews anfing arbeitete
ich bei Sky News eines Morgens riefen
sie mich an und sagten eine neue Studie
ist rausgekommen und wir wollen dass du
darüber berichtest daran hieß es
teekreuzungen sein total gefährlich und
müssten dringend durch Kreisverkehre
ersetzt werden
ich auf die nächste Live-Schalte wartete
las ich die Nachrichten es hatte eine
riesige Explosion in Bagdad gegeben mit
vielen Toten
und
people ich fühlte mich so nutzlos und
hoffnungslos als ich da an diesen
Kreisverkehr stand und da dachte ich
ich muss hier weg ich muss etwas anderes
machen
vergangene Nacht sind die ersten 1000
Iraker aus der Region um Mossul in
diesem Camp angekommen einige haben ihre
Familien seit Jahren nicht gesehen sind
Familienmitglieder von ihnen durch den
is getötet oder bestraft worden
es war noch vor der madan Revolution in
der Ukraine
da war ich in der Türkei im Urlaub
fanden Proteste statt
große Proteste
herangehen fühlte ich etwas empfehlen
sich noch nie zuvor im Leben so
empfunden habe
ste was ich je gesehen habe
gleichzeitig auch das echteste was ich
je erlebt habe
when I'm coming back home my friend wenn
ich nach Hause komme sagen meine Freunde
du bist Adrenalin süchtig you are train
Alina aber nein ich bin süchtig nach
Wirklichkeit als Mensch muss ich selbst
erleben was in der Welt oder in meinem
Land vor sich geht humanity
[Musik]
es gibt Leute die kommen davon nicht
mehr los
Adrenalin Junkies die brauchen das und
ich muss sagen ich kann das zum gewissen
Punkt nachvollziehen in kriegs- und
Krisengebieten gelten andere Regeln als
in unseren hochkomplexen Gesellschaften
wo alles bis ins kleinste
durchorganisiert ist das ist sehr
einfach man macht sich seine eigenen
Regeln das hat doch was unglaublich
befreiendes
[Musik]
Espresso Kapseln für unsere
Espresso-Maschine die wir im Team immer
dabei haben vor allem immer sagen dass
das zweitwichtigste nach der
Kameraausrüstung muss die Maschine dabei
sein
also
wenn man das jetzt so macht wie man das
in dem liberalen Land machen würde was
Afghanistan ja mal war dann ist
ist sowas okay ne also einfach so eine
Andeutung dass man jetzt nicht irgendwie
das ist jetzt die Variante und wenn man
es dann streng machen will
und dann wenn man im Interview sitzt mit
seinem Taliban dann hat man natürlich
mittlerweile habe ich selbst schon dann
halt auch schon so merke ich so eine
Selbstzensur ne
verunsichert einen schon
[Musik]
wenn wir unterwegs sind dann sehen die
Leute am Ende das was wir aufgenommen
haben was sie nicht sehen ist das
Drumherum etwa wenn wir einfach mal 15
Stunden im Auto sitzen und nur fahren
[Musik]
letzten September
waren wir die einzigen die einmal quer
durch Afghanistan nach der Kundige
gefahren sind
[Musik]
zwei Autos sind unterwegs
zusammengebrochen
da hatten wir einfach Zeit da hatten wir
genügend Zeit zu sagen wir kommen diesen
Monat noch nicht zurück wir oder ich
fahre wieder hin sich auch mal treiben
lassen zu können das ist Luxus aber
generiert wunderbare Geschichten die
eben nicht schon jeder gemacht hat
das was glaube ich uns allen am meisten
inklusive den Afghanen am meisten Angst
gemacht hat waren die uralten
Holzbrücken und dieses knirschende
Geräusch wenn man mit einem 2 Tonnen
schweren Minibus mit insgesamt 8 9
Leuten ganz langsam über diese Brücke
fährt ist Markt erschüttert
so
[Musik]
in vielen Kriegsgebieten ist es so dass
es Hotels gibt wo alle Journalisten
zusammenkommen dann trifft man sich
natürlich in der Lobby ja läuft man sich
über dem Weg man kennt sich es gibt ja
nicht jetzt so viele Leute die
Kriegsberichterstattung machen und da
spricht man miteinander und da trifft
man interessantesten Mensch das sind
nämlich nicht nur Journalisten sondern
sind da Geheimdienste aus aller Welt die
hören wollen was die Journalisten sagen
das ist so eine richtige Lounge an
anderen Leuten und dann tauscht man sich
aus
aber wir haben auch im Kindergarten
geschlafen irgendwo auf dem Land weiter
gibt's kein Hotel da steht bei dem
Schlafsack auf der Matte auf dem Boden
wird dann von den Bauern bekocht und man
bringt selber was mit das ist finde ich
eigentlich noch interessanter weil man
dann noch viel näher an den Menschen
dran ist als irgendwie so im Hotel zu
sein und dann von rauszugehen und abends
zu wissen also draußen bricht alles
zusammen und man geht abends wieder
schön in sein schönes Hotel
wenn ich in Hotel gehe dann versuche ich
auf jeden Fall immer nicht auf die
oberen Etagen zu kommen also besonders
an Orten wo es wo Luftangriffe sein
könnten
viele Sachen haben keine nette
hotel-obby in der Nähe
da lebt man anders
[Musik]
wir waren in Ost Aleppo und
Barrel
Bombenangriffen alle Menschen die man
trifft sagen ja vielleicht bin ich
morgen tot vielleicht heute Nachmittag
[Musik]
kamen wurde die Stadt gerade heftig
bombardiert
dort und die ganze Stadt war eine
Frontlinie
man war nirgendwo sicher es war überall
gefährlich in dieser Zeit
wir konnten nicht sagen lass uns ins
Hotel fahren dort ist es sicher
an einem der Abende im Hotel sprach ich
gerade mit meinem Kollegen als das
gesamte Gebäude plötzlich anfing zu
beben und einige Fensterscheiben
sprangen heraus
wir hörten eine unglaubliche Explosion
wir erstarrten und dachten nur shit
draußen gab es gerade eine riesige
Explosion und wir wissen nicht was das
war
's in diesen Zeiten müssen Journalisten
zusammenhalten und Informationen
austauschen da ist alle Konkurrenz
vergessen
was ist da los wie kommen wir dahin mit
wem müssen wir sprechen wo ist es
gefährlich wo sollen wir übernachten
man merkt dann schon dass bei aller
Konkurrenz das immer noch eine Gruppe
von Menschen ist die sich gegenseitig
sehr respektiert die ihre Arbeit sehr
respektiert und wo einfach auch eine
menschliche Ebene immer noch da ist aber
klar natürlich geht einem das immer nah
wenn Kollege irgendwie zu Schaden kommt
die Bilder auf die die ganze Welt
gewartet hatte das serbische Militär
verlässt das Kosovo
meine Frau war schwanger mit unserer
Tochter wir saßen beim Frauenarzt und da
lassen wir in der Zeitung das ein
Kollege vom Stern in den Kosovo gefahren
ist und es erschossen worden
Volker Krämer 56 Jahre alt Fotograf und
Gabriel grüner 35 Jahre alt Redakteur
aus etwa 600 Metern Entfernung
eröffneten unbekannte wahrscheinlich mit
Scharfschützengewehren das Feuer wir
saßen da zusammen und konnten es kaum
fassen warum ist der hat er das gemacht
warum ist er in den Krieg gegangen wir
sind vom Frauenarzt zurück ich bin ins
Büro ich war damals bei Morgenmagazin an
dem gleichen Tag da wurde ich gefragt ob
ich in den Kosovo gehen würde
unabhängig zu meiner Frau hochschwanger
und habe gesagt ich habe das Angebot
bekommen in Kosovo Krieg zu gehen
soll ich das machen und er sagt sie was
fragst du mich ich frage es soll eh
schon längst beantwortet du willst das
auch so macht das hier in im Kosovo
herrscht sowas wie Anarchie es gibt
eigentlich keine wirklichen
Ordnungskräfte mehr
das ist war zum Beispiel so 2006/2007
2008 aus dem Irak auch sehr gefährlich
weil er zum Beispiel so Organisation wie
er keiner im Irak einfach auf die Jagd
auf Journalisten gemacht haben oder wenn
man sich zum Beispiel in Libyen Krieg
anguckt da sind ja auch Journalisten ums
Leben gekommen weil da die Fronten auch
unklar waren das sind auch Leute
verschwunden
und dann wenn man nicht sie islamischen
Staat sich angeguckt hat das sind ja
auch die ganze Zeit Leute
als Geise genommen worden teilweise auch
enthauptet worden das sind ja auch ganz
schlimme Sachen passiert
man muss wohl ein bestimmter
Persönlichkeitstyp sein um diesen Beruf
zu machen
aber es ist kein Spiel
real es ist echt es ist gefährlich und
es kann tödlich sein
Vize da
[Musik]
11 mai 2022 die amerikanisch
palästinensische Journalistin Shirin
awoakley wird während Dreharbeiten im
Westjordanland von einer Kugel getroffen
und stürmt
sie war eine Journalistin wie sie im
Buche steht
eine Autorität in Palästina und für
alles was dort passiert okay
sie zeigte mir und anderen dass Frauen
jedes Recht haben über solche
Geschichten zu berichten
ich kannte jetzt persönlich nicht aber
da natürlich viele Leute auch auch
Interaktionen hatten mit ihr und und sie
gut kannten und das auch dann erst an
einem auch natürlich sehr nahe geht ne
das einem auch sehr unfair vorkommt
naja sie waren nicht die erste
Journalistin der erste Journalist
der die
dort erschossen wird
was soll ich sagen
es hat mich nicht so wirklich gewundert
Bestellung ich arbeite seit 1998 als
Kameramann für Alja angefangen
ich habe den ersten Bericht für sie
gedreht und auch den letzten Bericht
[Musik]
um 6 Uhr morgens hat Shirin mich
angerufen macht euch bereit wir gehen
ins Flüchtlingslager Jenny
als wir angekommen sind war erstmal
nichts man hat uns gesagt dass die Armee
oben ist aber unten war gar nichts los
Shirin ist vor mir gelaufen ich hatte
ihn gerade aufgesetzt da wurden wir
beschossen
ich habe sofort auf Aufnahme gedrückt
als ich die erste Patrone gehört habe
das ist der Instinkt das Kameramanns
bevor er irgendetwas weiß
[Musik]
wenn Journalisten getötet werden trifft
einen das irgendwie sie machen ja den
gleichen Job wie du und man denkt das
hätte auch ich sein können
[Musik]
die Wahrheit ist immer das erste Opfer
das hat nichts zum mitkriegt zu tun und
im Krieg ist es vielleicht besonders
dramatisch an manchen Momenten aber das
einzelne seitenpropaganda machen das
hast du jeden Tag natürlich versuchen
die Seiten beide uns zu beeinflussen und
natürlich spielt
mittlerweile Informationen und
Propaganda
in Kriegen eine ungleich viel größere
Rolle als würde ich mal sagen noch vor
10-15 Jahren wenn man sich anschaut in
welchem Ausmaß schon in Syrien die
Propaganda aus damaskusarbeit zunehmend
aus Moskau ein komplett falsches Bild
dessen was sich dort abspielt wer dort
Massaker begeht wer dort
chlorgaserin und so weiter einsetzt wenn
man sich anschaut in welchem Ausmaß die
Wirklichkeit
aktualisiert wurde zumindest in der
Wahrnehmung in Deutschland in Europa ist
es umso wichtiger geworden
da zu sein und zu sagen nein das ist
Propaganda
[Musik]
was wir hinter uns sehen ist der Fluss
der durch die ganze Stadt der lepo
fließt aus dem Sie hier an dieser Stelle
in der Nähe der Brücke alle paar Stunden
die Leichen Fischen die weiterfluss
aufwärts in dem Teil der Stadt der vom
Regime kontrolliert wird hineinwerfen
Information ist eine Waffe
das sehen wir in der Ukraine ganz
deutlich es ist eine Waffe die in einem
Krieg sehr sehr entscheidend Situationen
verändern kann und die von Russland paar
excellence eingesetzt wird und es ist ja
auch Teil der russischen Militär Doktrin
Information als Waffe einzusetzen das
Ziel ist es die Leute so zu verwirren
dass sie nachher gar nichts mehr glauben
also Desillusionierung gibt so viel
Information rein und das den ist das
auch egal ob das irgendeiner glaubt oder
nicht sondern einfach nur so viele
Informationen und unterschiedliche
Versionen in den ETA hauen dass die
Leute nachher sagen es ist mehr zu
kompliziert oder es kann man ja eh nicht
nachprüfen und so also was stimmt denn
jetzt und die eine die die die die
Version
meine Rolle im Informationskrieg ich
habe keine Rolle im Informationskrieg
meine einzige Aufgabe ist es die Kamera
zu nehmen und zu filmen was ich sehe
[Musik]
mein Name ist mein Name ist Maria avjeva
vor dem Krieg war ich
forschungsdirektorin bei der European
expert Association aber jetzt bin ich
eher Producerin
kriegskorrespondentin Bloggerin
[Musik]
am 24 Februar sollte ich eigentlich zu
einer Konferenz nach Kiew fahren wo ich
einen Vortrag über russische
Desinformation halten sollte
ich die Bomben Einschläge
ich war noch nie zuvor im Kriegsgebiet
gewesen es hörte sich Angst einflößend
an
oh hier Bosch
ins movin Allah die Russen bewegen eine
Menge schweres Gerät in den letzten Tag
während ich hier stehe ich weiß nicht ob
sie das im Dunkeln erkennen können aber
hier fährt eine lange Kolonne
gepanzerter Fahrzeuge gerade in diesen
Moment vorbei
das war eine ganz surreale Situation wir
hatten eine Live-Schalte und dann auf
einmal an die Russen sind dann außen im
Graben mit irgendwelchen Panzern
rausgefahren an uns vorbei und haben
dann eine Kurve gemacht und sind
Richtung Ukraine gefahren oder free go
back in the distance aber wenn sie nach
der hinten schauen sehen Sie die Panzer
dort vorne abbiegen direkt Richtung
Ukraine
das ist der letzte Checkpoint bevor die
Russen ukrainisches Gebiet erreichen
viele Medien riefen an und baten um
Kommentare und Informationen wie ist die
Lage in der Stadt sind die Truppen
bereits in harkev angekommen sehe ich
Panzer sehe ich russische Soldaten
ich lebe nah am Zentrum wo in den ersten
Tagen die meisten Angriffe stattfanden
erstmal machte ich nur Videoaufnahmen
von dem was ich sah
Videos without me just the seens
[Musik]
aber ich habe oft erlebt wie die Russen
solche Videos anzweifelten das ist ein
Fake das ist nicht wahr das ist alles
inszeniert
also beschloss ich mich selbst
mitzufilmen um noch vertrauenswürdiger
zu sein
hier spricht Maria oft Jever aus harkev
Ukraine ich stehe vor unserem
wichtigsten Regierungsgebäude das in den
letzten Tagen von russischen Raketen
getroffen wurde
und das und es ging viral auf Twitter
mir war klar nachdem ich es gepostet
hatte kann ich es nicht mehr ändern
wenn russische Truppen nach haarkif
kommen
wir wissen sie töten und foltern
Aktivisten in den Regionen die sie
kontrollieren
ich versuche gut auszusehen trage immer
Make-up und ziehe helle Sachen an das
ist meine Weise zu zeigen dass die
Russen die Ukraine nicht kleinkriegen
werdens
wenn es internation als internationale
Medien nach hakif kamen suchen Sie nach
Leuten vor Ort die sich auskennen und
Dinge erklären können
ich begann auch fürs ZDF zu arbeiten im
Mai ging es erstmal nur um harkef
die Menschen mit denen ich
zusammenarbeite den vertraue ich auch
und ich weiß auch dass ich den vertrauen
kann producer sind Leute die einem bei
der Organisation hilft in der Regel das
sollten es Leute sein die vor Ort gut
Vernetzung gut verankert sind die uns
die wir da ja oft einfach nur
reingeschmissen werden
ein bisschen führen können das ist unser
Bindeglied zur Wirklichkeit
umso wichtiger natürlich in Ländern wo
ich die Sprache nicht kann der hat die
lokalen Kontakte der kennt der kennt die
Regeln der der kennt die Topographie der
weiß ja also da hinten gibt es noch ein
weg oder ich kenne da jemanden da kenne
ich noch jemanden und der spricht den
richtigen Akzent und Leute trauen ihm
das macht es sehr sehr viel leichter und
man kriegt einfach viel viel mehr mit
ich würde jetzt nicht einfach mit
irgendeinem mir fremden producer
losziehen
und mir von dem die Geschichte bestimmen
lassen auf gar keinen Fall das ist ein
ganz ganz wichtiges Vertrauensverhältnis
ohne guten producer kann man in diesen
Regionen gar nicht arbeiten deswegen
muss man sicher sein dass das
verlässliche Leute sind man muss immer
sich klar darüber sein dass diese Leute
auch eigene Interessen haben können also
Locals man darf nicht alles glauben was
sie machen man muss das ein bisschen
auch überprüfen und und gegenchecken
aber ohne diese producer könnte unsere
Arbeit niemals funktionieren niemals
ich denke ein gutes Foto sollte man im
Krieg nicht machen das wäre ja ein
schönes Foto ein schönes Foto vom Krieg
aber bringt die Leute dazu den Krieg zu
akzeptieren und das ist das Gegenteil
dessen was wir erreichen möchten
in den ersten Tagen schien mariopol fiel
ruhiger zu sein als andere Städte in der
Ukraine
russische Panzer brannten schon auf der
Straße Kämpfer
ich glaube deswegen sind viele
Journalisten von mariopol nach Kiew oder
in andere Städte gegangen aber wir
beschlossen zu bleiben
die Stadt wurde mehrere Tage lang
bombardiert es gab tote doch die Stadt
hielt sich noch ganz gut bis sie an
einem bestimmten Punkt einfach zerbrach
und auseinanderfield
[Musik]
über YouTube
wir hatten gerade Schutz gesucht
wir hörten ein Luftangriff liefen die
Treppe hoch auf ein hohes Gebäude
unseren rauchaufsteigen so smoke rising
from the city
also fuhren wir hin und sahen dass es
ein Krankenhaus war Frauen und Kinder
wurden aus dem zerstörten Gebäude
gebracht
Autos brannten
Rettungskräfte rannten herum
panikanik mehr es ist leichter zu zeigen
als zu schreiben
in dem Moment dachte ich okay wenn die
Welt das sieht wird das alles aufhören
[Musik]
natürlich nicht
ich bin nach Butscher gekommen kurz
nachdem die Russen dort abgezogen sind
in eine Stadt wie mariopolis ja niemand
von uns reingekommen aber Butcher war
das erste Mal dass wir gesehen haben was
ist passiert
in einer Stadt in einem Gebiet
dass die Russen besetzt gehalten haben
nach Informationen der ukrainischen
Regierung liegt hier hinter uns eine
vierköpfige Familie die von der
russischen Armee hingerichtet wurde
das war für mich schon
eine sehr schockierende Situation sowas
habe ich noch nicht erlebt dass man als
Journalist so nah an so etwas
herangeführt wird und das war schon hart
also da war eine Familie die da
zusammengebrochen sind da waren ganz
viele Leute natürlich
geweint haben und und sich auch auch gar
keine Fassung mehr hatten und dieses
Massengrab war hat sehr frisch also man
hat ja schon noch gesehen dass da
irgendwie so Arme und Beine rausgeguckt
haben die hat das die Leute waren halt
notdürftig begraben aber da sieht man
eben auch dass die Ukraine
ihre besondere Informationspolitik
machen die auch teilweise fragwürdig ist
es gilt ja schon
Opfer zu schützen auch die würde von
Toten zu wahren
und dass man jetzt da mal eine so große
Gruppe von Journalisten
zu so einem Grab führt wo die Toten noch
liegen erkennbar oder auch dass man eine
große Gruppe von Journalisten in eine
Stadt holt die sich dann da auf die noch
verbliebenen Einwohner stürzen die
traumatische Erlebnisse hatten und die
interviewen
das finde ich muss man auch in Frage
stellen weil eigentlich verdienen Opfer
auch einen gewissen Schutz
[Musik]
können Sie mir erzählen wie sie ihr Bein
verloren haben ja ich stand Schlange zum
Einkaufen
plötzlich kamen Flugzeuge und warfen
Bomben ab
im Auto habe ich das Bewusstsein
verloren
mehr weiß ich nicht mehr
das passen diese Person ist
traumatisiert ist es okay mit ihr zu
sprechen
du musst deine Erfahrung nutzen und es
selbst beurteilen
wir müssen schon auch
die schmerzhaften
und schrecklichen Geschichten zeigen und
erzählen
weil nur anhand des Schicksals von
Menschen lässt sich das Ausmaß eines
Krieges zeigen
eines Tages kamen wir zu einer
Feuerwehrstation die gerade von einem
Luftangriff komplett zerstört worden war
neben dem Gebäude stand ein Auto in dem
eine Frau lag die von der Explosion
getötet worden war
und ich erinnere mich noch an den
Konflikt der sich in meinem Kopf
abspielte ich sah diese Frau an und sie
hatte kein Gesicht
aber nichts
nicht
es war so entsetzlich dass ich es
einfach Filmen musste
damit es irgendwo festgehalten wird es
war fast eine Pflicht gegenüber dieser
Frau
musste
aber dann trete ich zur Seite und mache
ein weiteres Bild in dem der blutige
Rest ihres Gesichtes von dem Auto
verdeckt wird dieses Bild wurde dann
veröffentlicht
aber ich weiß ich habe noch eins gemacht
ich weiß es gibt noch ein anderes Bild
es ist einfach so
dass man solche Bilder nicht zeigen kann
das kann man im Zuschauer nicht zumuten
und es ist auch gegenüber den Toten
finde ich nicht akzeptabel das zu tun
gestern zerstörten Raketen der
russischen Armee bereits die Gleise
blockierten alle evakuierungszüge
insofern war die Menge der Leute die
hier gewartet haben heute morgen heute
Vormittag noch größer als sonst und vor
ungefähr einer Stunde schlugen hier
mehrere Raketen ein
drin sehen wir noch Blut Lachen das
Gepäck der Menschen
Kinderspielzeug das herumliegt die
letzten Habseligkeiten die Leute
mitnehmen wollten
das ist nichts als Terror was wir
passiert
man da bei Zeiten dann wirklich weg muss
und danach auch eine Weile braucht und
es ist einfach zu viel wenn man sie die
Leute eine Stunde zuvor gerade
regelrecht tranchiert wurden dort
aber ja jeder
jeden nimmt es anders mit und wenn man
merkt es geht nicht mehr dann muss man
weg
[Musik]
in der Regel freue ich mich natürlich
wenn ich nach Hause zurückkomme
manchmal bin ich dann ein bisschen
befremdlich über was Leute sich aufregen
bisschen
kleinkariert kommen mir die Menschen
manchmal vor aber meistens pass ich mich
dann relativ schnell wieder an weil es
ist ja auch mein Leben und auch ich kann
mich über leider völlig unsinnige Dinge
auch aufregen
das ist tatsächlich eine der Kehrseiten
dieser ganz dieses doch sehr spannenden
Berufs also
man erlebt Dinge über die man eigentlich
nur mit Leuten sprechen kann die man mit
denen man das gemeinsam erlebt hat ein
dritter wird das niemals verstehen
und insofern
verbinden solche
verbinde eine solche Arbeit in solchen
Gebieten enorm mit den Menschen mit
denen man diese Zeit verbracht aber dass
die einzigen Menschen sind die genau
wissen was in deinem Herzen los ist ich
glaube es hilft immer wenn man wenn man
so Familie hat weil wenn weil den ist es
natürlich egal wo man gerade war also
man muss dann erstmal den Müll
rausbringen die Küche machen die Kinder
wegfahren und sowas alles dass das hilft
enorm dann irgendwie da wieder
reinzukommen
es hat quasi im Leben gegeben da fand
meine Tochter das nicht gut und hat das
auch kritisiert und auch gerne mal als
Argument dann gegen mich verbannt so
nach dem Motto visuell abstimme jetzt
nicht auf die Party zu gehen ja weil das
zu gefährlich ist aber du fährst doch
nach Afghanistan das ist ja auch
gefährlich
[Musik]
ich erinnere mich im Januar kam ich
zurück aus Afghanistan
ich flog mit dem evakuierungsflug nach
Dubai
ein Tag davor hatte ich Kinder gefilmt
die am Verhungern war
Leute die ihre Nieren verkauften um
diese Kinder ernähren zu können
oder die ihre Kinder verkauften um
andere Kinder zu ernähren
und in diesem Flugzeug finde ich mich
auf einmal in einer übertrieben reichen
Gesellschaft wieder
das sagt erstmal nichts schlechtes über
die Gesellschaft an sich aber es zeigt
doch eine seltsam ungleiche Welt die so
sehr aus dem Gleichgewicht geraten ist
dass es weh tut
die Bernd
ich reise von einem Ort zum nächsten
Bilde Beziehungen treffe unglaubliche
Leute sie lassen uns in ihr leben wir
hören was ihnen passiert ist wir hören
Herz zerreißende Geschichten und wir
sehen herzzerreißende Szenen und dann
packst du deinen Koffer und gehst nach
Hause
du hast es gut du kaufst dir einen
teuren Kaffee das ist einfach Pizza
das Arbeiten hilft immer
ich war in den ersten Wochen und Monaten
des Krieges durchgehend beschäftigt das
hat mir geholfen weiterzumachen
ich hatte gar keine Zeit um den Horror
zu fühlen oder über die Gefahren
nachzudenken
ich möchte zeigen dass Krieg brutal ist
das schlimmste was passieren kann most
und nichts was man ständig wiederholen
sollte definitiv
[Musik]